most high school seniors probably don't
spend a lot of time watching the us
treasury market but thanks to this
year's sell-off it will be a lot more
expensive for them to get a loan for
college student loans distributed this
year will carry the highest rate in
years
4.99 percent i'm going to explain how
federal student loan interest rates are
calculated why rates will be so much
higher this year after touching a record
low just two years ago and what this
means for the cost of a college
education let's get into it the
department of education determined
student loan interest rates by combining
a fixed add-on rate with the yield on
10-year us government bonds at the last
auction in may
that just happened undergraduate
students receiving loans from the
federal government get the lowest rate
for graduate students it'll be a little
more than one and a half percentage
points higher and for professionals or
those receiving a parent plus loan the
rate will be a little more than two and
a half percentage points higher one of
the few good things to come from the
coronavirus pandemic was that students
who started college in 2020 got to lock
in the lowest student loan rates in
history the pandemic brought on a
recession and expectations for weak
future economic growth which kept
treasury yields near record lows in may
unfortunately for students headed to
college this fall those days are over
treasury yields in 2022 have risen at
the fastest pace on record to start a
year that has been the result of high
inflation and expectations for the
federal reserve to raise u.s interest
rates at an accelerated clip because the
10-year yield spiked leading up to may's
final auction the rate locked in by
student loan borrowers will be the
highest in years unlike with other loans
the rate on student loans is not
influenced by credit score or financial
profile this will make the cost of
borrowing for college a lot more
expensive
undergraduate borrowers who got their
student loan in 2020 and borrowed the
maximum 5 500 in direct loans will pay
about eight hundred dollars in interest
over ten years that same borrower who
got a loan last year will pay almost
eleven hundred dollars in interest and
this year that borrower will pay almost
fifteen hundred dollars in interest
that's almost double what they paid two
years ago
and while the interest rate doesn't
change during the year students
borrowing for the typical four years of
college will get a different loan rate
each year the rate for federal student
loans is generally lower than private
student loans but not always since those
are based on credit and typically
require a cosigner for the student
there's currently about 1.75 trillion
dollars of student loan debt outstanding
that's likely to rise even more soon
unless president biden goes through with
his controversial plan to forgive them
and with higher interest rates driving
up the price tag for college expect this
to become an even more hot button issue
paul wahl the people's champ taught us
how to deal with times like these he
said chasing checks now place your bets
i bet on me
now it's time to collect
numbers going up
price is going up
i'll see you next time